Okay guys so this is how you trade a continuation of the trend so obviously this is a handset
right but I just want to explain to you how you can trade the continuation of the trend
order flow in the continuation of the trend right so let me show you what's going on here so
we created a lower low lower high and then we created another lower low right this could be the
lower low right around here so what you can see here is that let me remove that we broke the
structure here and this there is imbalance around here right there's no imbalance here
here or here okay it's all filled so this should be our entry zone okay but then we got
auto blog here so this would have been your first entry okay and you would target
this zone right around here now once price creates creates another lower low which it does right
here you can see that there's imbalance around here and this is the auto blog okay there's no
imbalance around here every imbalance is filled within this trend so what do we do we take our
position from here put our shop plus right above there and we target the low here and as you can
see price hit our take profit level now let me give you an example for the buy positions